hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in section 7 of
notes from underground Fyodor Dostoevsky
has his main character / narrator set
out a very interesting examination the
critical analysis if you like of a lot
of different moral theories and how they
view human self-interest and advantages
or goods for us as human beings this is
targeting not just enlightenment or late
modern ideas and ideals but but also you
could see him targeting the UD monistic
ethics of the ancient and medieval world
as well and the question is the question
that that bedevils us that he's
struggling with is why do people do
things that are that are bad for
themselves and for others why do people
do stupid careless counterproductive
things and one answer for that again
this goes all the way back to Plato and
perhaps even before heaven then picks up
a lot of speed during the Enlightenment
is well they just don't really
understand their own self-interest
they are doing things that are
counterproductive they think that
they're doing something that's to their
advantage or that will bring them
advantages things that are good for them
but they're really doing the wrong thing
so they vote for politicians who are
gonna screw them over or they they spend
their money on frivolous things that are
not really going to make them happy if
we could just straighten them out if we
could give them the advantages of the
full education and moral development and
introduce them to you know a sense of
proportion
then they wouldn't make these foolish
decisions that hurt them and hurt other
people and so so Dostoevsky he says who
was it that first that man does nasty
things only because he doesn't know
where his real interests lie that if he
were enlightened about his true interest
he would immediately stop acting like a
pig and become kind and Noble being
enlightened the argument goes on and
seeing where his real advantage lay he
would realize that it lay in acting
virtuously in Haven like a good person
and developing their faculties or
whatever else we want to throw in there
right we would be in the harmony with
other people we wouldn't screw with them
we who wouldn't get in their way and
they wouldn't do that to us either this
is something that we have been dreaming
about for a long time but the question
is is there really a war a worm at the
core of this otherwise quite attractive
Apple and Dostoevsky is going to raise a
number of problems before we look at
those problems
let's look very quickly at how he
characterizes the people who think that
we actually can straighten humanity out
and and I would say by this he has in
mind you know for example the
utilitarians or the Marxists or the you
know anybody who's like following
Plato's ideal city or this or that or
this a million different proposals being
enacted within the MA
world from a variety of different
positions so he talks about people
drawing up lists and and series or you
could call it a hierarchy of values or
you could call it a way of prioritizing
however you want to understand it
there's a system that gets drawn up of
advantages things that are genuinely
advantageous to us as human beings and
he says that as far as I can make out
your you've based your scale of
advantages on statistical averages and
scientific formulas thought up by
economists and you know at the time that
he's writing and actually for a lot of
us today that would be how we ought to
do it you know isn't that what it
consists in being evidence based that
you've got some numbers and statistics
and some models and studies and things
like that behind what you're proposing I
mean never mind the fact that those
studies could be poorly designed
unwrapped look at statistics can be
massaged just put all that that stuff
that we know about you know social
science to the side and let's just
assume that everyone's acting in good
faith right so they they drop these nice
things
why wouldn't we rely on statistical
averages why wouldn't we rely on that
does your scale consists of such
advantages as happiness prosperity
freedom security all those sorts of
things aren't those the things that we
actually do in fact value and want and
seek after whether we realize it or not
when we buy ourselves that big color TV
that's that's new and it's thinner than
all the others and it's got you know
picture quality beyond what we could
possibly even discern well aren't we
just seeking our happiness aren't we
seeking advantage perhaps in a foolish
way maybe we should wait until you know
it's a lot of them have been sold and
the price drops you know that would be
to our genuine interest but you know
there's nothing wrong with having the TV
or the right kind of soda or you know we
could go on and on and on right the
prescribed amount of sex in your
romantic relationships the right number
of chill
perhaps his none perhaps it's you know
many or maybe it depends on where you
live what your income level is you know
the right amount of sleep the right
amount of diet the right amount of
exercise the right amount of all these
sorts of things well we have studies for
these don't we and he he talks about you
know people who are doing this that as
being humanitarians there are these
classifications and tables drawn up by
the humanitarians for the happiness of
mankind to make us genuinely and for the
first time happy
we've been miserable through all of
history and at odds with each other
why wouldn't we want this so here's
where the problems come up and these are
these are questions they're not
insurmountable necessarily but they're
things that those days says maybe these
people have not sufficiently attended to
they haven't really thought about it the
first one is well when the human beings
ever genuinely act just out of
self-interest I mean isn't that a huge
assumption to say that if we just saw
our genuine self-interest that would
motivate us sufficiently and we would
you know have sort of a irrevocable and
infallible approach to the good well
that's assuming that we actually are
motivated primarily just by our
self-interest don't we do all sorts of
things that aren't actually in our
self-interest because there well that's
because you don't know what the
self-interest is so it doesn't
sufficiently move you if you really did
know it then then that would you know
take care of it but he says what about
the millions of facts that show that
that men deliberately and in full
knowledge of what their real interests
were spurned them and rushed in a
different direction they did so at their
own risk without anybody advising them
refusing to follow the safe well trodden
path and searching for another one a
difficult one an unreasonable one
stubbornly working their way along it in
the darkness doesn't that suggest
something that perhaps stubbornness and
wilderness willfulness are stronger in
these people than their interests so
what we'll get
we'll get rid of the stubbornness we'll
get rid of the willfulness all right
fair enough here's another question
while can you define what actually is in
the interest of a person I mean there's
all sorts of attempts to do so the very
fact that there are so many different
systems out there hmm that might give us
a little bit of pause or we might say
well that's that's a great thing you
know the human kind is quite diverse so
maybe we need one system for this kind
of person and one system for this kind
of person but what we have to unify it
all into one vast coordinated system do
we really know can we really define what
is in the interest of a person maybe we
can in the general sense but then we get
to hard cases can we do it not just for
the aggregate or the generality of human
beings but do it for specific
individuals
that's a open question
another thing that Dostoevsky raises
which would be sort of just an absurdity
to say utilitarian or you know somebody
along those lines
well what if one's own interest demands
not just as compatible with but demands
something that is actually harmful to
them what if they want something that
makes them feel bad what if that's
actually in their self-interest what if
that Spurs us to greater things what if
we actually do as you suggest a little
bit later on
often desires suffering well then how
are you gonna take that into account
when you say well that's only for people
who don't really understand their
genuine self-interest but what did you
get to the bottom and you find that
there is a genuine self-interest and it
includes these negative aspects oh
that's a problem another big question
can you actually make an accurate an
adequate scale of all human advantages
can you fit everything in there
Dostoevsky is actually going to say so
just no and he's going to say that there
is a mole
advantageous advantage that always gets
left out well if that's the case then
our scales and timetables and whatever
it else it is that we're talking about
really isn't adequate to the task that
we're setting it isn't another issue
that he raises is the inconsistent
person and he says I have a friend of
course he's your friend too and in fact
everyone's friend when he's about to do
something this friend explains pompously
and in detail how he must act in
accordance with the precepts of justice
and reason moreover he becomes
passionate as he expostulate Sepang
hooman interest heap scorn on the
short-sighted fools who don't know what
virtue is or what's good for them then
exactly 15 minutes later without any
apparent external cause but prompted by
something inside him that is stronger
than every consideration of interest he
pirouettes and starts saying exactly the
opposite of what he was saying before he
discredits the laws of logic and his own
advantage he attacks everything and he
says my friend is a composite type he
cannot be dismissed as an odd individual
and you know what we have here is what
what in ancient times they called a
cross yeah
failure to follow through on what you
know to be true or good you know a
recognition that this is the right thing
to do and then not doing it
Dostoevsky is gonna steer this in a
somewhat different direction he's gonna
say well this shows us that there's
something else going on a little bit
later in a further chapter he is going
to bring up one other problems that that
could arise and this was in Chapter 9 he
says can't reason be wrong about what's
an advantage and this kind of goes back
to well what if interest demands
something harmful because he talks about
suffering here but what what if reason
is actually off-base what if reason is
not the tool to figure out what really
is an advance
for human beings well then we'd have a
problem wouldn't we and all of these are
problems that have to be faced and
addressed by anybody who's going to
introduce a scheme that would say that
well the reason why we screw up as
individuals as groups as society in
general is because we don't really
understand where our true genuine
self-interest lies we don't understand
what really is to our advantage if we
just got straight on that we'd all be
great people we'd all be virtuous these
are the problems that have to be
addressed if somebody is going to
maintain that point of view and not just
be essentially committing themselves
blindly
in a faith commitment to this utopian
dream of fixing people fixing humanity
you